the jurgen experience are kelly's still
in jail too
i believe so damn that's [ __ ] up [ __ ]
why
huh why why is it [ __ ] up that he's
still in jail or kelly
why is it [ __ ] under our kennedy yeah
then they had some [ __ ] jams
i'm not saying he shouldn't be in jail
he should be there it's a waste of
talent
imagine if they said
imagine if they made a deal with him
they said listen you can
you can take months off of your sentence
with each album you put out oh my god
wow
and all the money goes to charity hey
man you need to be the new attorney
general
hey man you can't yeah
i have a [ __ ]
listen mr moses let's make a deal if you
were the opposing
if you're the opposing lawyer and you
and i met and we decided let's just
smoke a joint and talk about this man oh
well yeah it's just hard
you know right now with all the [ __ ]
that had happened with r kelly it'd be
very very difficult
to listen to a new r kelly album
and he didn't talk about it did you
listen to the one that he did release
the one song that he did release no
listen man it's pretty [ __ ] good
he's the [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] but he's
got great songs people got upset at me
that i said listen i understand
he's an extremely flawed human being but
this song
is pretty [ __ ] catchy who was that
one that he released on soundcloud
after he got like dropped by his is it i
believe i can fly a remix
there was no there was a song he was
talking about having a flight risk he
was talking about his whole
thing not guilty this [ __ ] has a soul
called not guilty
he does r kelly does he yes
probably we might see eighteen songs in
a
row
uh best of both worlds right remember
trapped in the closet
right remember that trapped in the
closet yes he had a whole city
he had a soap opera yeah yeah trapped in
the closet he did
our kelly is he let him out for for
coving kelly's an innovator man
everybody else africa he's an r b he's
the king of r b oh okay
a 19 minute song called i admit i know
that's
it yeah dude yeah i heard 19 minutes
it's good it was like trapped in the
closet all together listen i'm not
saying i endorse
what he's done i do not know we're
separated saying
what i'm saying is the sounds that he's
making
the the the things that he's saying you
can apply them to what you think he did
or didn't do and it'll [ __ ] it up for
you yeah bro if hitler puts out a
[ __ ]
r b soul album tomorrow with funkadelic
on it i'm not
yeah i'm not like forgiving him no i'm
not forgiving what i'm saying is what
i'm gonna tell you you're getting hitler
yeah
that's your jam i do think some of them
[ __ ] and them families and them uh
[ __ ] and [ __ ] like that that was
letting their daughter go with r kelly
they knew what the [ __ ] they was doing
like i'm not letting my daughter go with
r kelly nowhere [ __ ]
or any [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like what every black parent said
when they watched that documentary they
were just like
if i ever let my daughter go yeah i'm
not letting yeah i'm not what the [ __ ]
is going on you know what i'm saying it
didn't like the [ __ ] with the hotel i
think a lot of that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
but i think r kelly a nasty [ __ ]
and he needed to go
to jail but you know what i'm saying
here's the thing yeah
i think that he let him be a hoe but he
was just dipping in
shallow waters man yeah you can't do
that r kelly like i'm like
don't be a hoe with some older like some
girls and it's like man you rich as [ __ ]
you have any woman you want why do you
want to [ __ ] with a [ __ ] that can't
even drink at a bar with you
i think there's a there's a madness of
that kind of fame
yeah like the the level of fame that he
had and
you ever see that one video where he was
on stage and these girls
literally reach up and grab his dick
while he's dancing and singing in front
of him
imagine sinatra in a similar
circumstance
oh my god i want you to stop and think
and i'm not saying that sinatra did the
same [ __ ] that r kelly did but i want
you to imagine
i want you to imagine oh [ __ ] what kind
of
kind of a connection does this man have
to his fans
i mean he is dancing in front of these
ladies in there
he's singing to their face and they're
patting him down
and people are screaming for the people
that are just listening to this
this is wild [ __ ] it's wild i mean this
is
jesus christ it's wild but they grab his
dick eventually there it goes
there he goes she's massaging his dick
while he's singing
this in front of everybody hey this this
one his last shows he did
he's telling
[Applause]
listen we need jimmy fallon's and we
also need our kellys
we need hyenas and we need lions
keep on wiping me we need republicans
and we need democrats we need everybody
everybody but um is she wiping his ass
there was some [ __ ] that he did
that was different than this the problem
with this guy is
the stuff that he did was like you start
looking into it and you go jesus how
how old is everybody like what is this
it's like
the stage [ __ ] like doing that the art
that he produced like being able to
stand on stage and this girl grabs his
dick in front of everybody
i'm not endorsing anything he's ever
done ever that's criminal but that is
wild that is [ __ ] that's wild yeah
anything else will do options yeah i
feel like they were doing that [ __ ] back
in the day
you know but like that like girls don't
panties on stage
i know but they're grabbing his dick in
front of the whole world i mean
you ever seen the five heartbeats oh
this is my favorite hold on timeout this
is my favorite r kelly song do you have
your passport
did you get your shots do you wanna come
back with rob to america do you have
your passports
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god look look the background six
is like what the [ __ ] are we seeing
they just met me like that is
pure madness what was that one
what was the one where the girl calls up
and he's mad he's getting his hair done
what is that one where where the he is a
whole thing
where he's going back and forth with
this woman
what is this song no no no no no no
she's mad at him and he's like [ __ ] i
wish you would
burn my [ __ ] real talk that's
real talk
[Music]
[Music]
man you know what
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's right and what's
[Music]
listen to this listen she said there
were other guys there
did she stay there were other guys there
were there
other guys there well tell me this
how the [ __ ] she know i was with the
mother girl
wait a minute let me finish what i've
got to say
[Music]
give me a little bit more give me a
little bit more i don't care always
accusing me of someone give me a little
bit more
i'm just trying
[Music]
going through a [ __ ] pedophile
case
oh my is god always running off at the
mouth telling your girls your
[ __ ] business
when they don't eat with us they don't
sleep with
us besides what they eat don't make
us [ __ ]
look man ray charles couldn't see r
kelly couldn't read man
[ __ ] both write a goddamn song catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience